good afternoon
my name is paul narvaez i'm a principal
engineer at intel
i work in a
different part of intel than most of you
are probably familiar with um there is a
very large health and life sciences
sector
uh working on a number of very
interesting
projects in personalized medicine
what we provide um
in here is
essentially expertise uh in big data and
in computational performance
and we're trying to enable a new
ecosystem
this revolutionizing the way medicine is
is being done
in the world
um i'm going to give you a very brief
overview what we do um i only have 20
minutes uh you know feel free to contact
me afterwards
for any follow-up or discussions
i hope
this gives you a little bit of a break
from other types of presentations and
something
you might hear something new here
so let me just start with some basics uh
a little bit of history here
you know this is something i just took
out of wikipedia this is everybody knows
this this is a simple
curve showing moore's law
spectacular the way that uh
processors have uh progressed since the
early 70s
so you can see 40 years of worth of
processor design
i've been following a very very
uh
accurate exponential growth here right
this is a logarithmic chart um and we do
see that
the so-called moore's law really is
uh working um
and even
people have been predicting the demise
of moore's law for many years and we
still have moore's law working for us um
this is a great thing
um and and this really has set up the
expectation of what a cpu can do and
what
machines can do
you people expect every 18 months you're
going to have something
you know exponentially
faster happening
for much of the initial days of the cpu
design this really was
everything you cared for
every time you would have
uh a new generation coming out this
generation would be automatically
50 faster 100 faster in speed
there was very little that software
engineers or
applications you just needed to know
about compute it was you automatically
got
the speed up the
hardware engineers um in companies like
like like intel
build a faster processor the software
guys used it period
however
sometime
around the year 2000 people started
predicting
there was going to be some kind of
tectonic shift going on
the reason for that is
yes moore's law is true more or less
still works
you can put
twice as many transistors in a chip
every 18 months which is great
and you can use that to make things
faster which is great
however as you make things faster you
make things harder
if you kept the progression that was
going on from the
386 all the way to pentium 4
and by the way this is a graph from the
year 2000 when people started looking at
this problem
today we are about
0.015 so we are somewhere over here
we would have hit the sun surface
temperature a while
ago
so clearly that's when people realize we
can't just make things faster
by taking advantage of moore's law
if you're a complete computation a
computer company or a computational
company you cannot just
run things faster
you really have to
looking in a different dimension
um
the person who wrote this this graph
used to be an easel fellow
pollock's rule was basically saying that
yes you can you can you can use this
additional area that's in the die
because your transistor count keeps
growing and growing
but
the increase in performance is only
about a square root of your complexity
so if all you care about is single
threat performance you're gonna your
improvement is gonna eventually
uh not scale
and so this is when people realize that
really power consumption or or heat
is really what's limiting single threat
performance
we have to go to different type a
paradigm
um and this is what what happened so as
you can see
going all the way down to the the early
1970s
uh we had pretty much the same thing
going on right and the whole world
revolved around this very simple
paradigm which was just
you write software to run a single
thread
the the
the computers get faster and faster and
you don't never have to worry about
software again and you have a very
simple division between software and
hardware
and in 2005 well in 2000 is when people
started realizing this wasn't going to
scale
in 2005 five is when it really didn't
scale anymore
um and you can see it very clearly here
the frequency is no longer going up
when when you buy a new cpu today if you
buy a new cpu you're not expecting your
new cpu to be four gigahertz or eight
gigahertz or 10 gigahertz we pretty much
stopped at 3 gigahertz or 4 gigahertz
it's not it's not going to go beyond
that
and if you look at
performance on a single thread
it's also leveled up
what has changed is the introduction of
parallelism
parallelism and also specialization
and this is where you see
number of chords going up that's one
form of parallelism
but you also see that in terms of what's
inside the cpu which is a lot more
complexity
you see that in terms of parallelism
with simdi which is a
vectorization
form of parallelism and new instruction
sets
so the processors are becoming more and
more complicated
um
but if you ran the same program that you
wrote 20 years ago
today
you probably would have seen pretty much
no benefit over the last 10 years
or maybe five years
so what does this
you know what does this mean
it means that in order to get benefits
of
this new paradigm
you really have to have the entire
ecosystem
uh
understand two concepts parallelization
and specialization
parallelization means that i can run
things
on many cores
or many compute compute engines
so that i can scale by having
my processing done in many places as
opposed to doing the ultimate processing
in one place at a very high speed
specialization means that i can
run
my computation on the type of hardware
that is most efficient
this means that if i have an accelerator
i can use an accelerator if i have some
custom hardware that addresses a
specific type of compute problem or
specific kernel i can use that
because our chips are getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and everybody else's
chips as well
there is plenty of real estate in the
chip
to put as many accelerators or special
type of
compute engines as you need
so the key really is in going forward is
how do we
work with the rest of the ecosystem so
that we take advantage of this
and i have just a couple of
examples here uh what's really in a
hardware repertoires you know
multi-cores is
a key thing
vector units is huge um
it it's amazing uh what our you know new
processors can do in terms of vector
instructions and this means you can
essentially pack lots and lots and lots
of
values integers or floating points in a
vector and process them together
the new specialized instructions
you know graphical processors not just
intel's but
you know nvidia gpgpus and so on
heterogeneous computing is very
important
fixed logic accelerators even fpgas
and we've recently announced a
new server
uh product for example that has an fpga
embedded
in your cpu that allows you to
work in this type of model where you
have
not everything running in a single
thread but you can offload depending on
the type of
of compute
what this means
for the company as a whole is that this
is a very complex ecosystem
where we can't just design chips
in the abstract we really have to work
with the different applications and we
really have to understand
what are the workload demands
and this means that we have
really worked very tightly over the last
five or ten years with the domain
experts and software developers so and
you'll see more and more of this that
we're not working on in
isolation but we're working with
scientists with software developers with
industry
to design
together
all right so how does this hit
healthcare
healthcare is a fairly
also a fairly complex ecosystem
you
you have a lot of interacting parts
it's different than other verticals that
we
deal with like oil and gas or
um
financials here you really have a lot of
moving parts so
um you know life sciences the
bioinformaticians this is genomic this
is huge and i'm going to talk about that
today
but you really can't just do progress in
one of these sectors without
realizing okay there's also a payer that
has to pay for that
they're going to have to have systems
that understand this there's also a
provider that's going to have to use
that information
the doctor needs to know what the
uh genomic result is
if you know if i have the infrastructure
in place to sequence everybody in the
world
but the doctor can't use that
information it's useless right so there
are
there's a whole set of it infrastructure
that has to be developed as well to be
able to digest that
and of course the patient also has to be
connected to this
all right
so this is just a general slide
let's give you an idea of all the things
that we we're doing to tackle this
problem
um
this is a
general list of the types of issues that
we find every day when we talk to
customers and partners here
performance this this idea that all so
much software just runs on a single
thread
and is under utilizing complete
resources
uh poor scalability of algorithms
predominant problem we're seeing
um
you know being able to work with with uh
domain experts like bioinformaticians is
an issue and and finally databases is a
huge is a huge deal
how to actually handle all the
information all the data in a way that
is friendly to both compute into the
human being is is a challenge
it gives you an idea of the number of
partners we have here
we have projects with all these various
institutions
um
going from you know hospitals uh like
oregon health sciences university or the
mayo clinic
all the way uh to appliance builders
amazon web services and so on
all right so now let me get into some
concrete examples i'm not going to i'm
going to stop talking in general terms
and i'm going to give you a specific
example of a collaboration that we've
done
recently to to
speed up um
the way that uh
genomics works um
genomics is a is is a really interesting
problem to us um because
we can see that not too far down the
road
we have we're going to be facing a major
big data problem here
uh this is just uh
back of the envelope calculation
if
a certain part of the population gets
sequenced um if you know 100 of the
newborns in this country got sequenced
we'd end up with something like 313
exabytes worth of data
uh similarly if every patient gets
sequenced every two weeks every cancer
patient gets sequenced every two weeks
we end up with something like 500 right
so
these are really vast numbers nobody
really knows
how to store this in a database that is
useful
to
um you know country as a whole
so
in order for this to happen and there's
willingness to have happen at many
levels
uh things really have to change
all right so here's here's my finally my
concrete example uh the broad institute
is uh is leading uh
world uh institute for for genomics they
were uh it's a consortium between mit
and harvard uh they were responsible for
for sequencing the first um you know the
first human genome in the human genome
project
uh and they're leading other efforts
today like the thousand genome projects
and
and such um they have a uh
they're responsible for for much of the
software uh and algorithms and methods
that are responsible how do you do how
do you actually sequence
a genome
and i'm not going to go through the
details of this but this is a this is
sort of the kind of a recipe book taken
from their website
there's a sort of phase where you're
trying to
get get your um
all the pieces of a single single
person's genome together
you're combining multiple genomes from
multiple people and then you do some
sort of analysis together called joint
variant calling in which you're trying
to find out what are the differences
and then you're
doing some analysis with those
differences afterwards
there is a very important piece the only
thing i want to highlight here is which
is
joint variant calling which is the part
where you take all this data
and you're trying to find out what is
different for each individual
so if i'm comparing my data to my dna to
the dna of all of you
there is something in me that most of
most of it is exactly the same 99.9
percent of my dna will match yours
exactly but there will be that 0.01
percent
that is different and that really
matters
and so it's really critical to
to
be able to detect that with fair degree
of confidence and that's what this
component is doing
so when we first started talking to
broad um
this was taking about 100 hours
or even above that for high coverage of
thinking 200 hours
so just do that one component the whole
the whole thing would take several
hundred hours
and
we did this in collaboration with
another institution the oregon health
sciences university which is a hospital
in the portland area
where much of my team is is located
the first thing we realized is that the
way that the pipeline was being run is
extremely inefficient
uh was taking a lot of hours we spent
some time to optimize this
uh introducing things like
algorithmic improvements through level
parallelism cluster level parallelism
bringing it down to 44 hours
uh beyond that we realize that we really
have to go into the details of the
software
uh and work with with broad and that's
what we did we chose that one component
that i mentioned before
um let me think that back a little bit
so one of the things we noticed is when
we started profiling
various data then by the way there is a
tool that we released
open source right now
to be able to do this kind of analysis
on how
not just genomic workflows but pretty
much any any
medical workflow
performs on hardware
we
we wrote a tool to do this these types
of graphs and this type of analysis and
it's released open source
um it's called workflow profiler
um and what we've noticed is that as you
can see over here
the um
the lines
this is cpu utilization most of the time
most of this most of the cores are not
even used right there's there are huge
spaces here where
we're not using cpus
um
likewise
um
i can show you with memory
modern servers have hundreds of
gigabytes of ram right and
and many of these workloads are hardly
using any memory except maybe during
some some peak times
so
there's a lot of room for improvement
there's a lot of room to to write
software that actually uses the features
that are in the hardware
that for the most part in all the sort
of bioinformatics fields that we're
serving are not being used
all right so let me get back to the the
variant calling problem
we we profiled that workload that was
taking 100 hours and we realized that
the
the heart of the whole problem was this
kernel
so this is a very complicated piece of
software had
tens of thousands of lines of code part
of a bigger program program that
hundreds of thousands of lines of code
but 70 of the runtime was just
these lines of code
they were written in java they weren't
taking advantage of
of um
data locality
uh or any of the features of
we we decoded what this was trying to do
we figured out this is trying to do a
hidden markov model calculation
we figured out what the dependencies
were
and i'm not going to go through the
details of it
but it was fairly elegant
in that
we really have we first computed one
value
in this matrix and then we have a
dependency here
where there are other two cells in this
matrix that depend on that first value
and then there are
uh three other cells that depend on
those two values and then and so on
and there's a progression uh when you
run this
um
the way this was being run is that
each cell was being calculated
independently so you first you calculate
one cell then you go to the next cell
and you go to the next cell
each cell it takes a certain number of
steps
what we did is we rewrote the pro we
wrote those few lines of code in a
vectorized manner
that means is that
instead of treating each cell as my
variable i treat each
anti-diagonal as a variable that's
called a vector
so i can do this calculation
one chunk at a time
so for example in in terms of
calculating those
values over there i can i can calculate
it in five steps
instead of doing it in what would that
be um 5 4 9 12 14 steps as you can see
as this gets wider and wider
it saves me a huge amount of time
um that was actually a fairly easy
fix
but had huge impact it meant that
instead of taking 100 hours to do this
this
computation
it was taking only
30 hours so
huge difference um
the the results were actually kind of
spectacular we got 970x speed up
compared to the original version so once
you start using vectorization
the optimizations that you can do in c
plus plus plus
multi-core we can actually be able to
prove that we can run a thousand times
faster than java
uh you know if you look at the downloads
of gdk over time um the version that we
improved actually became
the
the the most downloaded version ever of
gtk and jtk this is this uh um you know
genomics pipeline
so it had a you know vast impact on
industry
um that's why one is one specific
example that i have now i'm just going
to give a very brief overview of other
things that we're doing
um
there are a vast num many many other
types of software out there in the
bioinformatics world
the left is
more on genomics and the right is more
on molecular dynamics we have teams that
are working on all these codes and
optimizing all of these
i don't know if you're familiar with any
of these but uh
the there we've done some
uh pretty um
pretty good improvements in many of
these cases
um we also partner with a lot of
companies and startups
uh we have a partnership with a company
called asd uh where we also
used adx
vectorization to get
um
speed up so we saw 400 improvement in
their uh operations uh we also have a
collaboration with scripps um in which
we saw
for also forex improvement for but for a
different reason this was about about
faster io using ssds
aspara is a company that does um fast
communication over network which is
actually very important these data sets
are huge
so ftp doesn't work you have to use
something
faster than that we've collaborated with
them to do that
sanger institute is a very famous
institute in the uk
we work with them in terms of storage
they're using a luster file system that
we've built for them
finally
in terms of appliances this is actually
a very key thing is you know taking us
an intel server
and being able to customize it
for life sciences applications is
something we did with dell
and
with a very nice story we were able to
cut down
the uh the delay for this was done with
dell in another institute in arizona
t-gen
uh and they were using this for for kids
that had uh
cancer
um and uh we were able to to bring down
the uh the time to do the rna-seq which
is a different type of sequencing not
dna with rna down from seven days to
under a day
which is kind of critical for some of
these
um you know very acute uh patients
likewise we have a number of
collaborations with a bunch of
appliances
uh to do this type of optimization work
in life sciences um
if any of you wants to build an
appliance you're you're welcome and
you get help from us and
that's it
that's all i have i think
as i mentioned before really our our
goal and this is being also stated by
our um
the head of our organization uh as in
servers as well as our ceo
is that we want to make personalized
medicine mainstream for 2020.
we do have a url
on the top that gives some examples of
the work we've done with industry
that's my email if you want to contact
me